what's going on guys welcome to screen
junkies you notice anything different I
hope so because we're no longer my mom's
basement I got kicked out but now I'm in
my uncle Gary's basement ah it's got
that new-car smell and other smells
welcome to the new screen junkies a
major television milestone is upon us
it's the 40th anniversary of Saturday
Night Live this weekend they are having
a huge 40th anniversary gala and we have
an awesome panel to talk about Saturday
Night Live with first she is a former
writer from Saturday Night Live and
she's a writer for Fox animation ADHD
Heather Kamp hi he's got his own Comedy
Central hour-long special coming up on
March 6 pretty damn cool Trevor Moore hi
so you also have an unusual Saturday
Night Live connection I was Lauren
Michaels intern for a year um did he
ever say hey come back with my dry
cleaning no never talk to me no as of
September 2014 there were 779 episodes
of Saturday Night Live
that would be 8000 sketches who knows
we're gonna talk about some of our
favorites Trevor watch start us off
what's once SNL sketch that you love one
of the things that I think that was
brilliant about Saturday Night Live was
that they as far as I know they were the
first people to do the fake commercials
so one of my favorites is the happy fun
ball it's like a little toy ball but
then when they read the you know the may
cause cancer may cause all these things
that just went on and on and on and on I
have is when I was a kid that was like
that one of the hardest times I think
I've laughed happy fun ball has been
shipped to our troops in Saudi Arabia
and is also being dropped by our
warplanes on Iraq
do not talk happy fun ball one of my
favorite sketches also commercial is
bass-o-matic ha ha which is an early SNL
dan Aykroyd schedule where they blend a
bass in a blender and then they drink it
now adjust the control dial
so that that fast is splendid just the
way you like it
no that's terrific bass since we're
talking about commercial parodies one
that I love is clucking chicken this
lovable chicken mascot uh talks about
how delicious the chicken is at the
restaurant and then we see him get
chopped up first my heads cut off heads
off then I'm plucked and gutted my
intestines are pulled out trust me you
don't want them well we're talking about
our best our favorite sketches from SNL
some of them are really politically and
socially conscious are there any that
you feel have like political yeah I mean
I think one of my favorite is extremely
political it's called robot repair um
and it's a sketch about robot hosting a
repair show uh-huh has absolutely
nothing to do with what people are
saying that robot repair indicates that
broken robots will be repaired when in
fact what happens is that a robot me
shows you how to repair a variety of
things I agree that the name is
confusing and I have asked the producer
to change it well I actually happen to
have a politically socially conscious
good that's also funny cuz you don't
want a political sketch that's gonna
lecture to you want something that's
gonna be freakin funny the Eddie Murphy
going undercover as a white guy yeah
does shake what you won this is back
anytime or don't we don't care huh are
there any newer sketches from yeah maybe
in the 2000s that there was a sketch
that Bill Hader did called herb Welch
which was about a extremely old reporter
who is belligerent to the people he was
interviewing you chef Graham I knew
about the
you angry turn over in his grave no he
wouldn't her because chef Cramer was
cremated they burned my friend okay come
on
backstage we're in the writers room it
made me laugh constantly I like Brian uh
fellows yeah Tracy Morgan I'm Brian
fellow that's it take him away this is
my show that bird is not funny and I bet
not see him again hopefully we will fix
this in editing so we've talked about a
bunch of our favorites and some of the
impact of SNL now let's shift gears go
to speed round I'm gonna just throw out
some iconic SNL sketches that we haven't
talked about yet more cowbell more
cowbell yeah yeah that got annoying fast
I got a fever and the only prescription
is more cowbell oh the Chris Farley
Chippendales probably as funny as it was
when it came out like that's and that's
an evergreen
this isn't forgotten one but I really
like um an escalator stops and they are
stuck in the middle of the escalator and
they treat it like they're trapped on an
elevator and it's really really funny
it's one of my favorites did anyone call
for a rescue Oh God so we're definitely
gonna get hate mail while we get even
more hate mail if we didn't mention Matt
Foley David Spade laughing is one of my
favorite parts of that sketch like he
can't keep it together Ryan from what
I've heard you're using your paper not
for writing but for rolling doobies
you're gonna be doing a lot of do be
rolling when you're living in a van down
by the river
okay guys we've talked we've gone here
and there and back again but now it's
time to get just bottom-line it greatest
SNL sketch of all time whatever my
favorite a thing of Senate live has
probably been all of nor McDonald's
Weekend Update if that counts as a
sketch I don't know but like that we'll
give it to you alright I was it felt
like a guy had a television station
hostage and this week 3 million Yankees
fans gather on the streets of New York
to honor their heroes well the fans were
of different ages races and religions
they shared one thing in common they
were all standing in urine if people
didn't laugh he would just stare at him
it was amazing it isn't that so damn
good Heather uh my favorite SNL sketch
of all time is the mark Jensen family
Christmas okay uh largely forgotten
sketch from 2001 starring Will Ferrell
he's on a platform singing it's the most
wonderful time of the year yes the happy
it's going too fast it's very short very
simple and it's just a puking joke okay
keep it players toggle yeah oh I don't
know how he pitched it okay so I'll be
on this thing there be a choir behind me
Wow I'll be spinning in place but the
platform will be spinning too fast and
then I'll start throwing up cool if I
were gonna pick it's ridiculous to try
to choose but I'd say the census sketch
with Christopher Walken and Tim Meadows
how many people live in this residence
oh boy that's a good question I'm bad
with numbers maybe 80 Christopher Walken
can just say anything that his wife is a
bobcat you are a convicted criminal
living alone in an apartment with a
bobcat and you work 56 hours a week as a
street performer when you say it like
that my life sounds pretty damn good
ah there's just so many good sketches
out of what is your favorite SNL sketch
of all time what we leave off our list
let us know in the comments section
below best answer we're going to send
you a screen junkies t-shirt also we
want to cover this place with your fan
art check out this super awesome screen
junkies crew as the Avengers one of our
fans made this that's me screaming like
a weirdo with all sorts of cool crap
around me draw something paint something
check out the description below for
where you can send your art I want to
thank my awesome panel or in honor of
Saturday Night Live and the wood
paneling on our set the Garth is to my
Wayne Heather Campbell check her out
she's all over the place and follow her
on Twitter and follow Trevor Moore on
Twitter and check out his special on
Comedy Central March 6th and follow me
on Twitter I'm Hal Rudnick thanks for
watching bye bye
bad boys versus the rock at number 5 Wow
I don't think Nick's enjoying this
experience it is hard and it sure is
hard